hey reject nation how you doing Greggy
Johnny so we're gonna watch the official
trailer for venom literally it was
cookie my dinner
getting ready to go to bed because we're
going to a very special screening bright
and early tomorrow morning but you know
what we do hey you can't let a leaked
image sit for very long without covering
it up with a trailer of course you guys
who don't know we do full-length TV show
reactions over at our patreon as well as
weekly Q&A page from the day shop for
David Gandy today dandy to Mandy David
Gandy was a such a kind-hearted soul he
sent us over a bunch of gifts out of
nowhere you don't meet too many people
like that these days the guy calls
himself an introvert ty reminds me of
like an eddy Brocken away if he just
gets some type of drink in him or
drugging him he's like a whole different
being he is like a dark sexy being John
you're gonna riff off that I'm just
thinking of spider-man three now which
you know I can see David Gandy doing
that I don't think David Gandy could
ever truly be evil but I could see him
doing you know like a little jazz dance
with his jet black you know symbiont
hair is ready to snap he's ready to snap
any second now and this might be the
trailer that does it yeah well let's I
think we're actually gonna see venom
this time let's do it perhaps you should
be afraid nice I'm just slightly cheesy
just off that let's see
dream of cleaning history starts today
I'm man
an association guy who for is an evil
person I don't want my phone works
payment are you gonna behave yourself
tonight I told you more than one job
reported several people that do not want
to be followed
what about the allegations if you
recruit the most vulnerable for tests
that end up killing people we have to
learn how to hide in plain sight
pretty good at it okay you son
whoever you are my foundation and I need
your help
we found Jenny sweet we call them
symbiosis
what is the totally sick
[Music]
you're not doing just in my head I'm
gonna need mr. Drake's property back
if you either stay you will only hurt
bad people whatever we do we have a deal
similar zhim
Wow
thing you almost did
what the hell are you we
uh-huh it seems like an October film
doesn't even like an October release I
think Tom Hardy is gonna be the main
captivating piece of this honestly the
movie to me just looks okay it doesn't
look like it's gonna be great doesn't
look groundbreaking I feel like it'll be
an entertaining time and it's primarily
gonna be in big thanks to Tom Hardy's
performance oh yeah because he brings a
ton to everything I like the contrast
between like a empt bra you know he's
like a nice guy you know a New Yorker
vibe who's a totally different being the
scenes that I was appealed to were the
ones where he's just like walking down
the street every conversation would
venom inside of his head you know those
moments are the parts that look the most
entertaining to me the venom stuff looks
pretty cool to me I mean venom has his
own comics is the protagonist of his own
comics and this trailer sort of
convinced me that even if it didn't sell
me 100 percent this could work and a lot
of that's gonna come from Tom Hardy and
how he does both Eddie Brock and Eddie
Brock under the influence of the
symbiotes and stuff yeah I mean you get
a little Jenny slate but most of what
you get from this trailer is just Eddie
Brock and the venom situation and it
looks pretty cool sometimes I feel like
the effects aren't done so some of those
last moments were that there was some
weird trailer ADR to going on yeah so
some of those moments where he's flying
off the motorcycle and the arms like
reach out and catch it I'm like no but
you know it's a little too early to tell
those kinds of things but this gave me
more Hope than I had going yeah when you
finally see the full figure of venom it
looks scary
it looks imposing and I feel like we're
really gonna get a personality of venom
as well you get a lot of Eddie Brock
here but the venom character seems to be
more than just evil stuff Tom Hardy did
the movie legend where he played to
different people and this is essentially
him playing two different people again
yeah and that's what gets me really
jacked about this I think it could work
without spider like seeing this little
bit here hey MIGO oh we don't need I
didn't even think about spider-man not
one time did I even think like who the
spider-man stuff you know who yeah yeah
and I'm pretty sure that was music from
the Avengers trailer right familiar it
sounded like the Avengers trailer I
don't want to say that for 100% for
certain but it definitely sounded like
it was right
message to send especially after all
that we're not connected we're just
gonna borrow your trailer music a little
bit but maybe we're connected now I
don't know maybe that's a tease for some
future announcement that's coming my
association with yeah that's true
what I also really liked about the
trailer was some of its horror aspects
to like it did start feeling a little
bit like a horror movie
I'm just really wondering what the
overall tone of the movie will actually
be because a lot of it I think this film
will really work based off what the
overall tone of the movie is because I
don't want misplaced comedy because what
seems interesting to me is like Tom
Hardy feels like he'll bring a sense of
humor to certain scenes which I like I
just don't want there to be like offbeat
humor at times you know I don't want
there to be jokes but there are
inherently funny or humorous about just
this weird transformation he's about to
go yeah like the fun and games part when
he's getting that when he had to send me
on her name and he's just taking out
these bad guys it's like upgrade but for
Ben yeah and Michelle Williams is in it
oh yeah playing a female paint playing
bottom line Eddie Brock looks like a
really entertaining character venom
especially that money shot looked badass
he that it looks like a scary ass
imposing venom I'm in for it sure watch
it even if I thought it look like crap
I'm willing to be pleasantly suppose yes
if this movie turns out great and okay
that's awesome but right now I feel like
it's gonna be a good time with a good
Tom Hardy yeah we're at this point
alright guys well thanks for watching so
late at night or early in the morning if
you're just waking up you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification rather get notified every
time one of our vids is up and you can
check us out on patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly Q&A is would love
to have you become a peach Rhonda check
today